katie's here she's got a new album smile
drops on august 14th well i'm about to
drop a lot of stuff
actually my uterus is dropping right now
as we speak
how are you doing with your pregnancy by
the way because
this is a particularly difficult time
with covet 19. do you have a plan
of course i have a plan but i think 2020
is the year where if you make plans god
laughs
so i have been really going with the
flow and i have a couple of ideas
um for that date coming soon
very soon thank you for getting up early
i know that's a drag especially when
you're pregnant and you're about to
drop you know i don't i know i was like
it could be like this morning it could
just all start this morning
if you would have been so fun for you oh
my god like going
through it together would you mind
jumping up and down so that that will
stimulate you
during the interview try to bring
something on yeah
make those contractions that'll do it no
but i mean at this point i know where
you're at your pregnancy you got to be
anxious to give birth already it gets
very uncomfortable
actually i'm not anxious at all i guess
i feel super blessed i've had a really
easy one physically and i'm very
active you know i have like a little
headquarters where i make
a lot of content and video and
performances
i mean i am a mom on the move as i say
and um i feel like i'm i think my fans
see it
that i'm really i'm i'm doing the work
for this record and then
once the record come and the baby comes
you know there'll be a transition
the album is called smile this is her
baby
her baby before the baby the baby is
actually
right let me see that oh my goodness
okay hold on hold on
let me see your belly wow look at that
it's in there that's the real baby and
obviously
you know when that baby comes out
they're not gonna
give a [ __ ] that their mom is katy perry
they're just gonna be like
feed me and what are we gonna do about
her marrying this orlando we gotta get
him up to the altar this covet is
[ __ ] everything up
honestly of course that will come in the
future but for now we
just want to deliver a healthy child and
that is what's coming up
that's what's teeing up right now